well consent has to be documented but it
also has to be informed and informed
means you have to understand what you're
consenting to
you needed to be walked through in great
detail
all of the issues that were relevant to
you on the psychological and medical
front all the options that were
available to you and the pros and cons
of all those options I can't see in any
possible way that that could have been
done with any degree of thoroughness in
something under six months of weekly
therapy and I would say that's an
absolute minimum to walk anyone through
something as complicated as what you
laid out
the problem with me starting it so young
was not only that I couldn't consent I
couldn't really fathom
the full just the full picture of things
you know I'll never be able to
breastfeed
um I'll never have that erogenous
sensation in my chest back
I do I do hate to speak about it but
I'm experiencing
sexual dysfunction at the age of 18.
that's something that women usually go
through
when
when they're in their 40s to 50s
how is this supposed to know
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening on
YouTube and on The Daily wire platform
Associated podcast we have a rough one
today so uh buckle up I'm speaking with
Chloe Cole an 18 year old so-called
d-transitioner from the Central Valley
of California she started her transition
at 12 years old puberty blockers and
testosterone at 13 and had a double
mastectomy at 15 years old she is now a
strong Advocate against gender ideology
and seeks legally to hold those
propelling It Forward accountable
hello Chloe Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas thanks for agreeing to talk to
me today and to to everybody who's
watching and listening you've been
through quite a a complicated experience
to say the least for the last five or
six years and you've decided in recent
months to go public with your story and
also to initiate some legal proceedings
against the medical professionals who
um what would you say aided you in your
exciting journey and so do you want to
tell us exactly tell us the situation
you're in now and and tell us about
what's happened to you since you were
well since you emerged from childhood
yeah so
at the age of 12 I started experiencing
some gender dysphoria and um
I started seeing a therapist and I got
the diagnosis and I started going
on the path of medical transition at the
age of 13 starting with blockers and
then
moving on to hormones and at 15 I got a
double mastectomy but
it turned out that it wasn't
the best decision for me and I stopped
transitioning at the age of 16.
okay so let's go back to when you were
let's go back to when you were 12. well
about when did you hit puberty
um I had a fairly early puberty actually
started um I started developing at
around the age of nine if not a little
bit earlier
okay okay and so
um
so at nine did that do you remember if
that changed you emotionally
yeah it did I
it was really difficult for me actually
okay so let me give you a little
background you tell me if anybody's ever
told you this before okay so boys and
girls
experience before puberty experience
approximately the same levels of
negative emotion so that would be
primarily anxiety and emotional pain or
even sometimes susceptibility to
physical pain and emotions like
frustration and disappointment and shame
and guilt and self-consciousness are all
part of that what would you call it
network of negative emotion now what
happens to girls when they hit puberty
and no one knows exactly why this is is
that their negative emotion levels go up
and so that on average women
biologically mature women are more
sensitive to negative emotion than
biologically mature men and that kicks
in at puberty now there's a variety of
explanations for that but no one knows
for certain and here's some of them okay
so first of all
sexual dimorphism and physical strength
really
emerges at puberty so boys and girls are
pretty evenly matched physically but
once puberty kicks in boys are taller
stronger heavier and they're much
stronger in terms of upper body strength
so women are at a disadvantage
physically in relationship to anything
that might have to do with physical
combat and so on those grounds it makes
sense for women to be somewhat more
sensitive to threat
okay so then the another explanation is
that
um women are more vulnerably sexually
than men because they bear a much higher
cost for reproduction obviously with
pregnancy and protracted dependence of
infants and so it makes
so they're they're more vulnerable on
the sexual front so it makes it makes
sense for them to be more sensitive to
any threat that's associated with sexual
activity and then the third explanation
and there may be more is that
women are charged generally speaking
with the primary responsibility for
infants and infants are extremely
dependent and vulnerable
and so you could make a case that adult
women's nervous systems are actually
adapted for the mother child dyad and
not for the say emotional well-being of
the individual woman
and a woman needs to be threat sensitive
because she's going to be taking care of
infants and an extremely dependent
children and it makes sense for her to
be more cognizant of threats as a
consequence even though the negative
consequence of that for women and all of
this is that women are much more likely
to suffer from depression and anxiety
than men
cross-culturally it's between three to
one and five to one now men have their
Associated pathologies men are more
likely to be anti-social for example and
to abuse alcohol but women predominate
on the negative emotion side and so
and then I would say that's exacerbated
you know if you hit puberty early
because you have to deal with these
complexities of physiological
transformation at a very young age and
so that's a difficult thing to handle
emotionally and then there's the
additional consequence of whatever
hormonal uh turbulence might emerge as a
consequence of the onset of puberty so
it's very common for young women
to experience high levels of negative
emotion and for those emotions to be
focused on their body because another
thing that's characteristic of female
negative emotion is that the
self-consciousness associated with that
tends to focus very particularly on body
shame and self-consciousness and that
might be because women are evaluated
more rigorously on the basis of their
physical appearance than men men are
evaluated more harshly sexually let's
say on the performance side you know
with regard to socioeconomic status and
so forth but women are definitely
evaluated more harshly by men and by
each other in terms of their physical
attractiveness so that makes quite a
complicated
situation for girls who are making the
transition into puberty and a lot of
them are depressed and anxious and that
and develop an intense focus on their
body so I don't know how much of that
was explained to you by your therapists
or the medical professionals but that's
all well that's all well-documented
psychological and medical information
yeah none of that was really explained
to me
by therapist or even growing up I mean
even so that all
every single part of what you said
actually played a role in
a lot of my childhood distress and my
transition and eventually my
de-transition actually you know um
growing up I was
a bit of a tomboy and also on the
Spectrum and I didn't know this until I
was diagnosed just last year but it did
play a role in my my socialization and
my difficulty getting along with other
girls growing up and I found that I fit
in more with the boys and when I hit
puberty um
it was a bit earlier than most of my
peers and I got taller than them and
oh yeah you know I had I I could keep up
with the boys then and I had a lot of
pride in that but as the years went on
they started to get taller than me and
outmatched me physically and this did
bring on a bit of distress for me and um
you know as I got older
um socialization become began to become
more
sex oriented and
I found it even harder to fit in with
girls my age and but at the same time I
was also starting to notice there's a
divide between me and boys
um and several ways and
there was there was a lot of loneliness
for me because on one hand I didn't
really feel like I was I was one of the
girls but on the other hand I was right
losing my connection with some of my
friends who I
was close with and really really cared
about
and I also had some body image issues
growing up as well um
I often talk about how social media
played a role in it but really it
started from a very young age actually I
mean I grew up I was born into a very
image oriented very sex-oriented society
and
you know before I hit puberty I was
looking forward to having a developed
body and eventually going breasts
and you know once I hit puberty and
once I hit puberty I was
it wasn't what I expected and I was
really quite disappointed how I looked I
was very very skinny I was on the
smaller chested side and you know I grew
up in an age where we kind of glorified
bodies that are very
um
very voluptuous lots of Curves people
often use a phrase like body I mean
bottom heavy or hourglass
pear-shaped things like that and I
didn't look like that at all I was you
know I was I was quite thin a little on
the muscular side and if anything my
shoulders were probably the widest point
in my body
and I kind of had a complex over this I
I also liked having my hair shortened
because of all this I felt like if
anything I didn't really look like a
girl at all I didn't like the other I
didn't look like the other girls my age
and I felt like
I just wasn't pretty and that I would
never
really have New York as a woman it's
it's a very rare Adolescent and probably
a particularly rare female adolescent
who feels attractive in the early stages
of puberty you know so everything that
you experienced although you may have
experienced it you know in an
exaggerated manner for some of the
reasons you laid out but everything you
experienced is in some real sense par
for the course for for a few years for
the vast majority of people now you did
add one additional issue which we could
delve into a little bit which I think is
relevant so you said that you're on the
Spectrum and that you had an easier time
communicating with boys than with girls
and so here's something to know about
that so the biggest reliable difference
that's been documented between males and
females and this becomes even larger in
egalitarian societies by the way
is orientation of Interest so women are
higher in negative emotion and they're
more agreeable and agreeableness is both
compassion and politeness and although
the difference between men and women
isn't massive
it's significant and it also maximizes
an egalitarian society so it looks like
it's biological but the biggest
difference is in interest
and uh boys males are more reliably
interested in things
and girls females are more reliably
interested in people
but people on the autistic Spectrum are
also more reliably interested in things
and so for example if you're extremely
autistic the psychological uh phrase for
for descriptive purposes is lacking
theory of mind and so extremely autistic
people have a hard time understanding
what's going on in someone else's mind
at all they they tend to be almost
entirely thing oriented and there's a
much higher preponderance of autistic
symptoms among engineers and then if
engineers in Silicon Valley for example
male engineers and female Engineers
often
by statistical comparison often Mary and
their children are disproportionately
likely to be autistic and so the fact
that you are tilted towards the the
autistic end of the spectrum first of
all that might just be an indication of
uh neurological wiring that tilts you
towards interest in things just so you
know that so that's not necessarily
autistic in and of itself it's just part
of the normal variation in in what would
you call it
well in attentional orientation but the
fact that you were
on the Spectrum let's say and more
interested in things is going to make it
more difficult for you to communicate
with girls because girls are reliably
more interested in people and so and
then on the image front you know this
this ties in with
the idea of self-consciousness so
if you're on stage and you're talking to
people and uh you become aware of
yourself tends to make you nervous and
sweat and to uh become uncomfortable to
experience high levels of negative
emotion and self-consciousness itself
looks like a manifestation of negative
emotion they're incredibly tightly
linked
statistically almost indistinguishable
from one another and so what you see
happening very often in girls because
girls are self-conscious in relationship
to their body because that's one of the
primary ways they're assessed let's say
for attractiveness and for social status
is that that self-consciousness tends to
take the form of intense preoccupation
with body and with image
and so that can be exacerbated by
whatever social trends happen to be in
place but it's it's a very deep-seated
problem and so that's part of and also
the fact that you hit puberty earlier is
going to make that obviously is going to
make that more complicated because it
means you're not as
neurologically or practically mature
when you have to contend with all these
issues
so everything that you described in some
sense could have been attributed to the
difficulties of normative development
just just so you know and this this
proclivity of teenagers to develop
depression and anxiety I want to take
that apart for a minute too for
everybody who's listening so imagine
gender dysphoria okay so 10 years ago it
was comparatively rare but not unheard
of but imagine it has two components
okay
one is a tendency towards negative
emotion so suffering anxiety depression
frustration disappointment pain shame
guilt self-consciousness all of that
and then imagine there's a sec second
part of it that's more specifically
focused on discomfort with the body
okay the first part of that
is the bulk of it so if you look across
forms of Psychopathology like mental
illness
the major segment is high levels of
negative emotion like depression and
anxiety
and a secondary segment is the
particular manifestation of that in your
case in body dysmorphia
and so and then the the claims that
uninformed mental health professionals
make that you're at elevated risk for
suicide if you're gender dysphoric is
erroneous because the elevated risk for
suicide is actually a consequence of the
of the general proclivity for depression
and anxiety and not a specific
consequence of the gender dysphoria or
at least that's only a small
subcomponent of it
so that's another thing to know is that
the main clump of psychopathological
manifestation mental illness is centered
on heightened levels of negative emotion
and of course that spikes for adolescent
girls now
you you may have been told this but
perhaps you weren't so there are good
long-term
studies of children with gender
dysphoria most of them were conducted in
Toronto where I happened to be by a man
named Ken Zucker and Zucker ran a
a clinic for gender dysphoric kids way
before this became part of the culture
War let's say and he was a very straight
and honest scientist a very good
researcher not a political person and
what he showed was
what his Clinic showed many
peer-reviewed studies was that
gender dysphoria of the type that you
described is relatively rare
but if you leave kids alone
till they're 19 or 18 80 to 90 percent
of them settle into their biological
identity
although about 80 percent of them also
are also homosexual in their orientation
and so the pathway
for him before this was all politicized
was you'd have a child who was
gender non-conforming temperamentally
somewhat like you were
you didn't have a pattern of female
interests let's say and so and then
prone to depression and anxiety and then
that combination would produce this
gender dysphoria and that would become
quite intense around the dawn of puberty
but if you just back the hell off and
waited
those kids would settle into their body
but generally I'd adopted homosexual
orientation and so that was as far as I
could tell that was the best research
now xucker got slaughtered for this once
it became politicized he lost his job he
was pilloried by the Toronto Star of the
newspaper here he won a lawsuit against
them just a couple of years ago but they
demolished his career and his his
guideline medically was
don't do any harm
right back the hell off you can provide
these kids with support and you can walk
them through their emotional problems
but you should but you should certainly
not rush into anything more dramatic now
you said
you started therapy when you were 12.
what were you told about what was
plaguing you
I think before I get into science and
there's some things I should bring up
before that I mentioned that um I did
have a late diagnosis for autism and
this is because
um
in preschool in my elementary school
years
um
my teachers often told my parents
actually that I had some
symptoms indicative of autism and they
suggested that they get me diagnosed but
when they brought me to my doctor as a
kid they were told oh she's too smart to
be autistic she's too socially developed
to be autistic and so I kind of miss the
best opportunity window the best ages I
guess you would say to get the diagnosis
it wasn't until after I stopped
transitioning that I got the diagnosis
actually
um okay and I find that
that played
a stronger role in my
in the development of my gender
dysphoria than my sexual orientation did
because
I'm
mostly mostly heterosexual I'm mostly
attracted to men and I mean I do have
like a very marginal attraction to other
women but it's mostly sexual nature I
don't really have any emotional
attraction to them and it's not
something that I've really ever care
about because
I mean it's not like I I do want to have
a family one day I do want to have
children and I can't really do that
naturally with a woman so I just don't
really see a point in it
yeah well there is some evidence by the
way too and I would say this evidence is
less compelling but
but I think it's worth contemplating is
that the the distribution of sexual
attraction in men looks like it's more
bimodal than it is in women and so there
seem to be homosexual men and
heterosexual men and not much in between
but on the female side there's some
evidence that women are more broadly
attracted to to
what
obviously most women are heterosexual in
their orientation but a higher
proportion of women report a
co-attraction to other women than men
who report a co-attraction to other men
and so why that is again isn't exactly
obvious but and I wouldn't say that
research is
incontrovertible but it's also worth
knowing because one of the things that
young women who are confused about their
sexual identity and their body might be
wondering is well now and then I feel an
attraction to another girl
what does that mean does that mean that
I'm not you know female in my Essence am
I not female physiologically I'm not
female psychologically and I would say
no it doesn't mean that at all it's
pretty damn common it might even be the
norm and I think most women
would
when pushed would make the same
statement that you just made about their
relative sexual attraction
so that's a good thing to know too okay
so back when you were 12. so you weren't
diagnosed with you were diagnosed a
little bit with autism when you were
young but you were told by your medical
professionals that you were too
intelligent for that diagnosis to be
relevant and so well part of that's this
distinction right it's it's complicated
because
what symptoms what symptoms did you have
of autism when you were a kid
um it was mainly social and emotional I
was very prone to emotional outbursts
and um
mainly getting along with and
maintaining friendships and also
I did also have some sensory
difficulties like with like certain
textures of Fabrics or certain smells
certain foods I wouldn't eat
so okay so it was mostly in the social
realm and what about your language
development uh was it was it normal do
you know I was Advanced actually um
I had taught myself to read and write
and I was further ahead of my peers in
that area
okay okay because one so yeah you'd be a
complicated case to to assess as a child
given your retrospective report because
another one of the Stellar what would
you say Cardinal card characteristics of
autism is delayed language development
and so that might have been partly what
the Physicians were referring to when
they said you know that you were too
smart to be autistic but then it's also
difficult to parse apart the fact that
it is a distribution and the mere fact
that you had difficulties in social
communication and were you interested in
things yeah like were you interested in
bill you were what about mathematically
um
what do we mean by that do you well are
you interested in are you more are you
interested in mathematics or are you
more literary in your orientation
um
definitely more more literary and I'm
also a bit of an artist I've I've always
liked drawing from pretty young age as
far back as I can remember
and so what what do you do on the hobby
side like if you're if you're just left
your own devices
um what what kind of activities would
you engage in
usually either like either illustration
or video games
and so you would you regard yourself as
a creative person yeah
Casey that's relevant too eh because
um
so creativity is associated with this
personality trait uh openness
and open people have pretty mutable
identities it's sort of the Hallmark of
being creative right is a creative
person isn't that stable in their
identity and I don't mean in the
negative emotion sense I mean they can
be one person or another they're
changing that mutability is part of
being creative and so
in your situation if you had social
difficulties if you had high levels of
negative emotion if you were
characterized by bodily
self-consciousness and you were creative
then you're a pretty good candidate for
the idea that your gender might not be
properly aligned with your physiology
you know you've got all the you've got
all the risk factors so to speak that
would
put someone in that category okay so
when you were 12 you started therapy and
why was that and what happened
um
so
I was about 11 when I got my first phone
and I started using social media
um the main platform I would use was
Instagram so very image orientated very
very image oriented right
um yeah it further reinforced and
worsened my my body image issues and
um
I was just force-fed a lot of content
that was just very difficult to take in
um
okay so tell me tell me about that in
some details so you're using Instagram
it's very image oriented platform and
you said that was really hard on you you
alluded to earlier you alluded to the
fact that you were looking at socially
approved images of women let's say
voluptuous women and you were drawing a
negative conclusion in or in
relationship to yourself and so exactly
how did that play out day to day
um I started comparing myself a lot to
like my family and the other girls
around me
um I mean a lot of my a lot of my female
family members are larger chested but I
got the smaller best of jeans and I was
really quite insecure about this and
even though I hit puberty earlier than
my other peers a lot of them were
outgrowing me and I felt like I just
couldn't keep up with other women
um and also
in a lot of my conversations or like the
conversations I would overhear between
other girls and women they often spoke
very negatively of being a woman in
general like the how difficult puberty
is and periods and how scary it is to be
pregnant and then give birth and
and then have all these expectations
placed on you as a mother and then start
aging start having these bodily changes
and then eventually go through menopause
and it was all painted in a very
negative light I never really heard
about the blessings that came with any
of these parts of
being a woman and so naturally
I mean I wouldn't want to start growing
afraid of that yeah right I also yeah
well you know when my
go ahead
um well I would also start seeing a lot
of feminist content at this time
um which kind of reinforced those same
ideas while also saying
things that were pretty scared to me at
the time like oh we live under a
patriarchy we're being controlled by Men
And They Don't Care About Us they're
taking away our rights and
you know I I don't believe that now of
course but
I kind of
fell into that that line of thinking and
I wanted
I mean with all this I just wanted
absolutely nothing to do with being a
woman I didn't want to grow into a woman
why would I
okay so two so two things were happening
to you you said
on the one hand
individually
you were suffering from the consequences
of your felt inadequacy in relationship
to these more voluptuous and like
clearly markedly feminine women
in in relationship to their physiology
and so you felt that that wasn't a
domain that you could necessarily
compete in and then also at the same
time you were being exposed to
social and educational material that
suggested to you that Not only was this
a game that you couldn't play very well
let's say in terms of your physical
appearance or maybe your temperament but
also that even if you did play it well
it wasn't necessarily A Game worth
winning that there wasn't anything
positive on the female front you know
when my wife was pregnant with our kids
one of the things that really struck me
and I never really forgot it was that so
many people would tell her horror
stories about
pregnancy
sometimes their own or sometimes the
pregnancy of other people that
um you know that they have known and
really do what they could to terrify her
and that always used to irritate me
because my wife actually really enjoyed
being pregnant I mean my daughter got
quite ill when she was pregnant so I
know there's a huge variation there I
saw that with my clinical clients but
it's not like there's nothing positive
about being female there's plenty of
positive about it but it's easy to
fall into a situation well where all you
hear is that well it's oppression it's
suffering it's vulnerability it's
victimization it there's nothing about
it that's all that's positive at all and
uh you know I think part of that's a
consequence of the higher levels of
negative emotion right a necessary
consequence of that because women are
more susceptible to to threat and
Punishment
but
that doesn't seem really to have all
that much to do in any real sense with
women's actual place in the social
hierarchy and the reason I say that is
because you see
as I mentioned earlier
there are societies that have become
more egalitarian and so where women
clearly have far more opportunity on the
socioeconomic front than they've ever
had in the past and those countries the
countries that have gone farthest down
that route are probably the Scandinavian
countries
and the consequence of that is that the
difference between men and women in
negative emotion is actually higher than
it is in traditional societies women
have higher levels of negative emotion
in Scandinavia than they do in more
traditional societies and so that
doesn't it doesn't look like the higher
levels of negative emotion that are
characteristic of femininity are a
consequence let's say of patriarchal
oppression
so there's no evidence to support that
hypothesis at all as far as I can tell I
mean obviously there are individual
women who are in abusive relationships
and who are genuinely being victimized
by you know Psychopaths and sadists but
as a sociological explanation doesn't
seem to hold water in fact quite the
contrary is true in any case you were
worried about how you could compete
physically and that's that's sad too you
know because men are actually
much less choosy so to speak than women
are when it comes to evaluating physical
attractiveness so for example virtually
every woman can find a sexual partner
and usually very quickly certainly not
true for men men rate 50 percent of
women as above average in attractiveness
whereas women rate 20 percent of men in
above average in attractiveness and so
you know this this variation in body
type that you suffered so much from
might not have been an impediment at all
to your ability to manifest yourself as
an attractive person in a reasonable
Society you know I can understand
because Instagram is a very heavy image
Laden platform and I can understand why
you might have been under a
misapprehension but one of the things
that a therapist might have done for you
is to help you explore the full range of
say body types that are classified as
attractive and to show you that you know
it's not you don't have to be J-Lo to be
attractive and that's definitely the
case and then there's multiple
Dimensions to attractiveness too that
aren't only body focused as well you
know I mean men do evaluate women on the
basis of their physical attractiveness
but that's not the only dimension of
evaluation there's there's more to the
story than that by a lot
so okay so you fell into Instagram and
you also started to become susceptible
to this
what would you say negative
propagandization about the female role
so you couldn't see anything positive in
that for you eh yeah and a lot of a lot
of these these feminists were kind of
downplay
I guess you could say like the
traditional role of a woman and the
importance of motherhood or even just
fulfilling a maternal role you know I
didn't really value that a lot growing
up because I was the youngest of five
kids and I never really had to take care
of anybody I didn't really know what
that felt like
um
and so I did I never really thought that
I wanted to have kids and so
a few years later
um after I stopped transitioning
actually I realized that I did have a
maternal Instinct and I really did want
to be a mother and have
um have blood children
um and that was an instinct that wasn't
really
fostered it wasn't really allowed to
grow at all because I was playing the
role of a boy and also taking
testosterone on top of that but um
you know at the same at Rough at the
same time that I started using social
media started seeing
um feminists content and
just the hell that is Instagram
um I would also see a lot of like LGBT
um focused content
um and a lot of it was
like teenagers and young adults who
identified as transgender or non-binary
and it was primarily young women
and I would I would often see they they
a lot of them had the same struggles
with as as I did
um socially and many of them weren't
exactly the closest with their families
and you know I would I would see them go
from struggling
to changing their expression and then
eventually becoming more accepted by
their families and it seemed like people
really supported them and had their
backs and that they had this sense of
community around them and that was
something that really touched me because
I was
I didn't really realize at the time but
I
that was something that I wish that I
had
okay so so you wish that you had what do
you mean a pure Community like when when
you're when you were feeling Lonesome
and isolated what is it that you were
lacking and what is it that you were
wishing for
um
I think mainly I really wish that I
had friends around me who I knew would I
could depend on
and when Kate did you have any friends
at that period did you have any friends
at that period of time
I did but I wasn't
I wouldn't say that I was
particularly close to them or that I had
very many at school I mean
um
I didn't really fit in at I didn't
really fit in in Middle School
um I didn't have a whole lot of friends
and I found that there was kind of a
favoritism
um among students by by staff and
I you know I was like a I was like a new
kid and you know I wasn't like really
involved in any sports or clubs or
activities or anything like that and I
was I was kind of a difficult student
and
um
I found that I was being bullied by both
students and stuff
right and I I also like to show you
I wasn't
like being abused by my family or
anything but I just wasn't very close to
anybody really I mean my my siblings are
old all older than me
um there's about like a right seven year
age gap between me and the rest of them
and I mean from a young age oh yeah yeah
they you know they became
they got older they started like hitting
puberty and becoming teenagers and they
didn't always want to
be around me they want to do their own
things so
okay so you you're having difficulties
on the body image front and that's
exacerbated by your temperament and by
early puberty let's say you're not as
popular with your peers as you might be
you're somewhat isolated in relationship
to your siblings because they're older
than you you're having a bit of a
difficult time socially in middle school
and now you're seeing on Instagram the
emergence of this explanation for your
problems that's generated by people who
sound like they have the same issues
that you do and what you see is that
when they adopt this new non or gender
fluid identity that well what do you see
what happens when they they have a
community all of a sudden people are
supportive of them like why did that
become attractive to you
I think I saw the similarities between
me and them in a lot of ways and
I mean when I was younger I was often
compared to boy and I I
and you know I liked I liked hearing
things like
oh you're being such a boy or wow you're
such a boy from like my older sister and
Mom and stuff
um
it just it just made me I don't know I
don't I didn't really know why at the
time but it just made me proud to
to
appear things like that I guess it just
felt like kind of an achieving because
you know I didn't particularly like
other girls and I didn't really like the
fact that I was a girl either and
especially as I got older I I really
wanted to weigh out and when I started
seeing this content it taught me that
there was and that I didn't have to be a
woman
we'll be back in one moment first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical Spirit to
which we're beholden is presented
precisely as that spirit that allies
itself with the cause of Freedom against
tyranny I want villains to get punished
but do you want the villains to learn
before they have to pay the ultimate
price that's such a Christian question
right well there is something
um
complementary let's say in some sense
about having those masculine attributes
those masculine qualities attributed to
you when you're a young girl because
they're often Associated when they're
positive with something like
courageousness and the willing to
explore willingness to explore and the
ability to sort of stand on your own two
feet and so you can imagine how that
might be attractive and then you also
were presented with a solution to your
problems in some sense right you had
quite a complex series of issues that
were besetting you and all of a sudden
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is something like and
correct me if I'm wrong I do not want to
put words in your mouth is that while
you have a non-standard gender identity
let's say and that means maybe you're
born in the wrong body something like
that now it's interesting in your case
because you know you actually your your
basic core fantasy was that you wanted
to be a fully developed and let's say
voluptuous one woman I mean so that was
really driving this but it if from what
I understand but you were worried that
wouldn't happen and then you started to
become concerned about the adoption of a
female identity and then there was this
alternative pathway that was laid
forward before you what was happening to
you in therapy at this time what was all
this was all this making itself manifest
while you were in therapy and how was
what role was your therapist playing in
this
yeah so right around the age of 12 I
decided that I wasn't actually a girl
after
some period of time questioning
my sexuality and then eventually my
gender identity I switched between
labels before I finally settled on
you know I think I'm just actually a boy
and I started cutting my hair shorter
gradually wearing more boys clothing and
I came out to my older sister some
friends that I was closer to
and at school and some people online as
well
and then after a few months I decided
that
I wanted to tell my parents about this
and also start
the path of medical transition and so
I wrote a letter
explaining to them that I wanted to be
their son and that I wanted them to
refer to me by a new name
and they were
they were
Beyond shocked they I don't really know
how as a parent you could expect to hear
something like this and I knew I knew at
the time even that it would be kind of a
it would be
it would be pretty pretty shocking to
them and so I wanted to allow them some
time to think it over and think of their
response I was also scared of how they
would react so that was why I wrote a
letter instead of bringing it up to them
face to face
um
they wanted to support me but they were
they weren't exactly sure of
what they should do
and so they wanted to seek the help of
somebody who
may be an expert in this who was more
knowledgeable in this and they thought
of it as like a psychological issue and
they wanted to
get to the root of it and so they sent
me to a therapist
and do you do you remember what what
specialization did you was your
therapist did you see a psychologist or
a psychiatrist a social worker do you
know do you remember
um I don't remember the I don't remember
his title I think he was just a generic
pediatric therapist and he the first one
I saw actually wasn't very thorough he
didn't really
he didn't even give me diagnosis I don't
think he didn't really go into the
reasons why why I was feeling this way I
was just kind of like
oh so your boy okay and then he just
never really got went into anything
which
let me tell you first well let me tell
you for a second what should have
happened okay just just so you know and
so that everybody listening knows so
when somebody comes to see you as a
therapist
you kind of have three questions that
are Paramount
the first question is well why is this
person here
and you don't know now what you assume
is something generically is something
like well this person is suffering and
Confused for some reason to the point
where that's become unbearable enough
that they want to seek outside help and
that's not trivial because people
generally don't seek outside help unless
they're pretty desperate so the first
question is well
this person is suffering why
and then the next question is well
is that something that goes along with
why is that something that's intrinsic
to them so is there something wrong with
them say in relationship to a mental
illness or a physical illness or is
there something about their situation
that would make anybody miserable if
they were in the same situation
and then the third thing is well having
sorted out that the person is miserable
and why they're miserable what could be
done about it and all of that should be
open for discussion right so if you came
to see me as a therapist I would the
first thing I would do is kind of what
I'm doing in this interview today is I
try to figure out well what exactly is
going on with you and you see that's
different than affirming your identity
right because you could come to me as a
client and say well I think I'm a boy
and the proper response for me as a
therapist is okay well you know you've
said that and
I want to find out why that is but I'm
not going to take that as gospel I'm
going to find out because we're trying
to solve a complicated problem here
which is while you're suffering and it
isn't exactly opposite obvious why in
fact it's not obvious at all and it's
not up to me as a therapist to LEAP to a
conclusion
it's up to me to talk to you and maybe
for hundreds of hours
find out exactly what it is that's going
on because I found out already look your
initial fantasy was that you wanted to
be female but you felt that in some ways
your body was failing you on that front
and then you looked for and then you
found out that being a female wasn't you
know maybe had some downsides and and
maybe all downsides and so then you were
looking for an alternative and you found
one that also explains some of the
difficulties you were having socially
that's what you've told me so far okay
but that doesn't mean we know what to do
about it yet right we've we've laid out
the problem landscape but the logical
conclusion of that isn't you're a boy
and you should go on puberty blockers
and then move towards surgery right
we're nowhere near that we're dozens of
hours or hundreds of hours away from any
decision like that and so
well so that's what should have happened
to you when you went for therapy you
should have had the time to lay out the
whole problem and then to have the space
to explore this really deeply so that
you could come to terms with what it was
that you need how you needed to move
forward okay so you said that
as far as I can tell so far you said
your therapist accepted the idea that
you
um
should be a boy pretty damn rapidly I
should also point out to everyone who's
listening that's actually now mandatory
by law
so any in many jurisdictions so now
because of standards of gender affirming
care therapists are required if you say
something like you're a girl you say
something like well I I'm a boy the
therapist is now required to agree with
you on pain of license loss
so beware everyone listening and
watching because that's now the law in
many places and so to me that's the end
of psychotherapy because all
Psychotherapy is is a questioning
approach fundamentally
you know to find out what the problem is
and then to try to work towards well
first of all non-harmful solutions
you know so I would have with you for
example I would have explored
some of the realm of Alternative forms
of beauty that would have been a nice
thing to to walk you through to some
degree so you could see more of what the
range was of acceptable and admirable
physiological types because that you
know I don't know for sure that we would
have done done that but we might have
because that would have been good for
you to to get a broader picture of
attractiveness right and then also to
tell you about the fact that a lot of
the misery that you were experiencing
was
well par for the course for females at
puberty but also exacerbated by your
your temperamental proclivities and so
that might help you calm down a bit
right because you get a bit of an
explanation for your misery that way and
also some hope that you'll that you'd
kind of grow out of it with time
so okay so you went to the therapist and
he more or less agreed with your
prognosis and diagnosis that you were a
boy okay so was the therapeutic process
of any utility to you
no he didn't really do anything actually
I was actually pretty to satisfied with
him
um
I did have some stuff going on at home
and at school that he just never went
into
um the full picture of my mental health
wasn't really explored at all actually
throughout the course of my transition
and um a lot of what I mentioned I
didn't even know was a problem until
recently and so well after I stopped
transitioning and I was you know I was
old enough to really be able to
introspect well enough to figure out
where it all stemmed from
but it was never explored by the adults
who put me on this path
okay so well so what did they okay how
often did you go see your therapist and
what actually happened during the
so-called therapeutic process
um
I was saying maybe about like once a
week to once every two weeks since
you know I would talk about
it's it's hard to remember so far back
but I remember yeah nothing really ever
came out of the appointments like I
would tell them like oh like my my phone
got taken away and I don't really have
like any contact with the outside world
for example and he would just be like oh
okay how are you doing with that and I'd
be like
um
you know not very well and he was just
he would just say okay and not really do
anything about it not really offer me
anything at all
um
and eventually I'd say after maybe like
a month or so he
maybe got like maybe got fired or he
transferred somewhere else because he
wasn't
um he wasn't there anymore and then I
got sent to another therapist and
roughly around that time I expressed my
parents that you know I'm not really
satisfied I want to go through with
a medical transition I want to go on
hormones and they actually pushed back
on this at first they were they were um
they're very cautious of this they
didn't know why I was pushing for it so
much and
they they wanted me to wait a little bit
because at this point in time I was only
13 years old I was quite young to be
doing such a thing and
um
they stay that way and so I got my
gender dysphoria diagnosis and during
one of the appointments that they're
that they're very for
um
they um
I can't remember who exactly it was it
was either through a therapist or a
nurse I think
um somebody who is involved in my
transition
um they told them that
like oh this is the only
pretty much the only means of treating
dysphoria there was like no regards to
any alternative treatments
um you know they my dad asked like about
the regret rates and they said like oh
dude
they didn't even I don't think they even
used the word you transition they said
like oh it's there's less than a one to
two percent regret rate and
um yeah they also told my parents that
if I wasn't allowed to go through with
this then I would be at risk of suicide
okay so I wanna I wanna take all of that
apart okay because every single one of
those statements is a lie so first of
all the American Psychological
Association and their guidelines for
gender affirming treatment makes the
case that and because of prejudice that
there are no good long-term follow-up
studies of transgender individuals okay
and they attribute that to prejudice
against transgender individuals which is
not the Reason by the way the reason is
is that there's a very low base rate or
there was of transgender dysphoria and
the follow-up studies
haven't been done in large part because
the surgical and hormonal treatment
regimen is relatively new but there are
no good long-term follow-up studies and
they actually complain about that and
then a couple Pages later in the same
document they say that well
it's necessary to affirm an alternate
gender identity because otherwise the
client or patient is at heightened risk
of suicide okay so first of all both of
those things can't be true there's no
way that people can know that suicide
risk is elevated if gender transition is
delayed unless the long-term studies are
in place and they already stated that
the bloody long-term studies aren't in
place so that's all just a lie but it's
worse than that
it's way worse than that you see
gender dysphoria is a variant of the
suffering that's associated with
negative emotion depression and anxiety
now depression and anxiety are the
primary drivers of suicidal ideation
not gender dysphoria per se
and so they're they're confusing the
source now you were and then
there is no evidence whatsoever that
transition of the medical sort actually
has a salutary effect on mental health
partly because the long-term studies
simply haven't been done and the idea
that we actually know from a research
perspective that a child is much safer
if they start transition
than they are if they don't
that's just again that's simply not true
Ken zucker's work has showed quite
clearly that if you just leave the kids
alone
then by the time they're 18 or 19 most
of them settle into their biological
identities now so the reason I'm
stressing this is because your parents
like many parents in this situation were
put in a very very difficult position
and I would say it's corrupt to the
point of malevolence what the medical
professionals are doing on this front
and that is the insistence well would
you rather have a live trans child or a
dead child which is I don't think
there's anything more toxic you can say
to a parent than that because that backs
them into a corner they because their
alternatives are then well you can let
your child go ahead with this
absolutely life-altering hormonal and
then surgical treatment or your child
can die and it's your fault because you
don't care enough and parents like
they're accustomed to trusting their
medical professionals at least to some
degree and accustomed to assuming that
they the knowledge they put forward is
valid and reliable and the information
that your family was given was none of
those in fact it's pathological to a
degree that's almost imaginable it's
criminal in my estimation what you were
told
because there is simply there is simply
no evidence that any of that is the case
there's no evidence that transitioning
kids are less likely to be suicidal
there's no evidence that that's the only
treatment path that works and there's
certainly no evidence that the that
there's no uh there's no alternative to
transition or or suicide it's so it's so
pathological I can't believe it but it's
no wonder your parents were pushed into
a corner you know because that's a
dreadful choice for a parent to have to
make
yeah they're definitely coerced into it
and um
after that they
obviously were more open to the idea of
me being medicalized and a gender
specialist
um
decided to refer me to
an endocrinologist
um the first one
who I saw actually was the only person
who really pushed back on this
um
after the appointment he said you know
you are you're very young you're
you're 13 and this could have some
negative implications for your brain
development going forward so I think
it's
that that is something that should that
should wait I'm not going to prescribe
these to you and
after that I was just referred to
another endocrinologist who after about
two or three appointments um gave me the
consent forms for blockers I started
about a month after that and then
I had another appointment
um
to sign off on the the forums for
testosterone
um
and my mom also had to sign off on them
um
this was the Browns late 2017
early 2018 and uh
I don't know if it's still true now that
you that you need your parents to if
you're a minor to sign off on forms for
hormones or anything like that because
they're trying to they're trying to push
for kids being able to independently
make that choice but um
you know I when I started when I was
reading these forums you know they they
lists a few a few side effects for
either of them but I was a perfectly
healthy kid before I started
transitioning so
you know it was kind of hard to
determine which of those I might
experience and
I was also I was barely a teenager you
know kid kids kind of tend to think that
they're Invincible that they're
that nothing could could get them but I
started experiencing some
some complications that affect me to
this day
Okay so
three questions what were you
experiencing socially at this time like
how broadly had you made your transition
known and what was the consequence
socially and then what were you
fantasizing about your life being like
if you were if you successfully
transitioned to a boy so to speak and
then what were the consequences of the
hormonal treatment so let's go through
those one by one what was happening to
you on the social front at this point
um so I was in eighth grade at this
point and I wasn't really like out to
anybody other than family and a few
people at school but my other peers who
I didn't necessarily speak to about this
did notice my change in presentation
that was that I started to look more
like a boy and
they weren't necessarily the nicest to
me about it um
but I was kind of ostracized amongst my
peers they would call me names and
there was there was one boy who would
harass me over the course of the school
year
um
and he
there was an instant with him that I
will bring up later but I wasn't
necessarily my peers weren't necessarily
the most supportive media at this time
um
but once I started on the
the uh the hormones and I started having
the physical changes
um
I'll I'll get into that later actually
okay so so and what were you what were
you hoping for you now you're I'm
presuming your fantasy life switched to
some degree now you told me earlier that
in your the earliest stages of your
transformation into adulthood you were
thinking about this voluptuous female
ideal and then bemoaning your distance
from that but now you've decided to
change Sexes essentially and so you have
a new vision of who you could be and
what life would be like I presume that
would be going along with that what was
what what were you expecting slash
hoping for and why did you believe it
um
you know I wanted to be
by this idea of myself in my head
that
you know I wanted to be more like
a man I wanted to be I wanted to be
strong both physically and mentally and
independent and not really have to
worry about how other people felt about
me and
I also wanted to be
I guess just more confident in general
than in myself as a person and also my
my body and once I start on testosterone
I started seeing all the physical
changes you know my hair my eyebrows got
thicker I started developing more muscle
um
my face and my body became more squarish
and I felt I felt good about myself I
felt like I looked good for
pretty much the first time in my life
and I felt like I had some control over
how I looked
and initially it felt great
yeah well testosterone can have that
effect directly pharmacologically as
well well okay so we can take that apart
a little bit look
there is nothing wrong with you wanting
to have those things right I mean why
wouldn't you want to be more confident
why wouldn't you want to be more
comfortable in your body and you know
those are perfectly reasonable goals the
problem comes in making the assumption
that the only Pathway to those goals is
physiological transformation right
because there's an idea there that well
if you're female
those goals are obviously impossible
it's like well no they're not there's
lots of women who are confident and who
can stand up for themselves and who are
courageous and forthright and like
that's perfectly within the realm of the
the full range of feminine behavior and
so a therapist who had any sense would
have helped you at that point understand
that there were practical steps that you
could have taken to bolster yourself on
all those temperamental Dimensions that
wouldn't have required anything radical
right they would have required well
first of all a vision and then a
strategy and then some diligent practice
you know and you could have made a fair
bit of progress on that I would think
within six months to a year with a bit
of alteration in your social behavior so
the idea that the only Pathway to this
was through
you know radical hormonal and
physiological transformation it's just
it's Preposterous and then of course
there's the additional complication
which would be well
you were enticed let's say into the idea
that you would be better off being a man
but
that's really not a pathway that's open
to you in some fundamental sense either
because there are physiological
impediments to that that aren't
that aren't
they can't be overcome I mean I I've
done a reasonable amount of research
into like penile construction for
example and to call that A Primitive
science is to give it far more credit
than it's due and so that's a huge
technical problem and then there's a
problem of course that lurks underneath
that which is even if you do manage that
which is highly unlikely and extremely
invasive and unbelievably dangerous and
very experimental and there's no
long-term studies whatsoever done on the
consequences you're still not going to
be fully physiologically functional as a
man you're not going to be able to
procreate as a man and you're going to
sacrifice your ability to have children
as a woman I mean this is a big bloody
sacrifice and so what were you were you
led through contemplation of those sorts
of things by your therapists
not really
um
they never really went in depth I mean
they would they would talk about like
the
to me about like the
they already talked about like the side
effects and also
basically give propaganda to my parents
thought this was gonna make me better
this is going to improve my distress and
make me happier and I felt the same way
I thought you know the the things I I
heard from both the Physicians and from
the research I did online basically gave
me this idea
that um
I was going to become my real self that
I would become the whole person in doing
this and it didn't it
it fractured by my sense of self even
further
um okay and this is something why did
fracture why did it fracture your sense
of self further what do you mean by that
um
there's a lot to that actually I mean I
was basically living life for a few
years that was that was very stressful
and I was trying to uphold this idea I
had myself in my head that was false it
was an illusion I genuinely believed
that I was somehow a man despite not
despite being a biological female
and in a lot of ways I missed out on a
lot of on on certain
developments mostly social
um I'm so
you know I didn't really go through the
crucial social female
socialization that goes that that goes
on throughout late middle school or high
ends in high school
um
I my dating pool was also affected by
this you know I was mostly attracted to
men I didn't really have much of an
interest in women but most of the people
who are interested in high school were
women and the few men who the few the
few
guys who
admitted attraction to me um it was very
it seemed very
sexual
in nature and it felt like if anything I
was just
like a like a fetish to them almost and
I didn't really I didn't want to I
didn't want to have anything to do with
that
mm-hmm
yeah that sounds extremely complicated
and there was there is also another
another element to it that I haven't
really spoken on before
um but I feel like it does have to be it
does need to be said it is kind of
uncomfortable because I was
just because of my age at the time and
it's also a very sensitive topic but I I
think I did also have some sexual
motivations in in doing this I like the
idea of like the changes that
testosterone would bring on to
my body and you know I guess
I mean people a lot of feminists and
activists who
speak against speak about like
transition transgender people and the
transitioners they often talk about AGP
or Auto gynophilia which is like a
I don't know if you're familiar with
yeah it's it's like a yeah
like a man so autographilia is the
fantasy it's a sexual fantasy generally
and then it often characterizes men who
become transsexual and start
cross-dressing later in life and they
develop a sexual they develop sexual
arousal from picturing themselves or
acting out being the opposite sex
and so I think some of that by the way
you know you talked about the fact that
you wanted to have some of the classic
male attributes masculine attributes
right like self-confidence and and
courage and so forth and that you were
complimented when you were referred to
in that manner I think a lot of a lot of
what happens to these men who develop
these sexual fetishes later in life is
that there is a part of them that's
crying out for exploration of and
development of their feminine side right
but instead of having that happen
psychologically and starting to
integrate let's say compassion and care
and and concern for people rather than
things instead of integrating those
cross-sexual proclivities they start to
act it out as if it's a Concrete reality
right and you were definitely enticed
into doing that but you also said and
you know don't let me delve into this
more than you're comfortable with but
you also said that there was a there was
a sexual the sexual elements
specifically so was there something in
your fantasies about what is what was
that was that about you being a boy you
said you were still attracted to women
so what
we brought this up we might as well
clarify it what was the nature of the
interaction with sexuality I mean it's
obviously relevant it was fantasies
about like yeah about being a man about
being about being
about being male and having like
masculine attributes to my body and also
a lot of it did involve like having like
a like a female partner which I never
really explored in real life because I
didn't have any emotional attraction to
women I didn't want to like have
I didn't want to
like have a relationship with another
woman and so I never really cared to
actually act it out but
you know this is so I guess you could
say
that I did have
like a female analog of
Otto gynophilia if if there's a word for
I guess it would be Otto androphilia but
I didn't really understand this at the
time because I was yeah I was so young
yeah well look I mean in adolescence the
range of sexual fantasy can be extremely
Broad
you know when there is a difference
between fantasy and real life I mean
people will fantasize about things that
they won't do in their real life and the
fact of the fantasies it can become
pathological if people dwell on it but
the fact that the fantasy covers a wider
range than Behavior would is actually
more an indication of the creative
capacity of fantasy
right I mean we'll do things in our
dreams for example or play out scenarios
in our dreams that would never occur in
real life and it's because part of the
human capacity for Ingenuity is the
capacity to imagine multiple different
scenarios and and some of those can be
extreme you know like I'll find for
example
um that if I'm angry with something you
know I can have quite violent fantasies
and I think oh my God you know where did
that come from but that doesn't mean
that I would act them out or at least I
hope it means that I wouldn't act them
out you know so our Fantasy Life is
broader than our actual life and you you
you border the acting out of your
fantasies by well by social necessity in
some sense so the mere fact that you
were having those fantasies that's not
an indication of anything that's in and
of itself pathological that's still well
within the realm of of normative
adolescent sexual fantasy I would say
you know maybe it was a little more
exaggerated in your case because of the
testosterone and maybe even to somebody
because of your more masculine
temperament but it's still well within
the range of normality so what happened
to you when you started taking the
hormones and and how did you react to
that
you know I start having some physical
changes like with my appearance and also
some
behavioral changes like I felt more
confident I felt I started to develop
kind of a competitive streak with um
especially with boys my age and I
started socialize just a little bit more
like they did
and I also
obviously because I was taking androgens
I also started experiencing
in a very strong increase in my libido
and it was very difficult to keep up
with and
um it started to become a problem with
me without me even realizing it um I did
unfortunately develop an addiction to
porn and I also
just had a very unhealthy relationship
was my body
and and sexuality and I still do to this
day
so on the porn front was that female
images are male or what was mostly
mostly female but
mostly female
okay so so it was mostly female but you
had no interest in establishing a
relationship with females and on The
Dating front you still wanted to at
least in principle you still wanted to
be with boys Jesus that's quite a
confusing message to walk through so
yeah no kidding you must have really
been going in five directions at the
same time during that period boy yeah
there's no clear pathway forward through
that so how in the world did you Orient
yourself
ah you know I didn't I I really couldn't
because I couldn't
I didn't really have like any dating
opportunities and
I just couldn't really explore that kind
of thing you know I had a lot of
this did become a bit of a source of
distress for me in high school
um
you know I I was I was frustrated I had
urges that I couldn't really fulfill and
on top of that I was watching all my
other peers get into romantic and sexual
relationships and had that kind of
development while I was just at least I
felt like I was
completely behind
right okay okay so all right so now and
what what what what kind of well those
are complex effects of testosterone what
would you say and the upside was you had
more confidence and more self-assurance
you were more competitive there was a
heightened sex drive which is a mixed
blessing what what were the what were
the negative consequences for you of the
of the hormonal treatment
um
sorry I also forgot to mention that like
um
because I couldn't find a partner in
real life I eventually turned to
dating online which was which only made
me more stressed because you know I had
these feelings for somebody that was
that
I couldn't even see or touch and
it just added on to my stress if
anything and um
I found that
if anything I just more often than not I
would just get used by other people
either either emotionally for for
support or for
um more intimate images of of me
but it was the closest I could get to
real intimacy and I was I was quite
lonely throughout High School I did end
up developing depression and this was
this was a big thing driving that
definitely
effects of testosterone um
you know at first
it made me feel great like it was
kind of comparable to stimulant almost
um
you know I find I
while I was on the blockers
um
I'd say there's about like a month-long
period between starting those and the
testosterone and during that period of
time because I had no sex followings in
my body I often felt very lethargic a
little bit depressed and you know I once
I had like the hormones back my body so
so is my energy that my energy came back
and
so there is there is
you could say that there was like a
little bit of a honeymoon period
um that lasted for maybe no more than
about a year and a half
um
but I found that I was more prone to
anxiety and
um
I also about I'd say about like a year
or so on testosterone I started
experiencing some difficulties with my
urinary tract I was I started I think I
got my my first UTI and then eventually
it devolved to me having like a
like being unable to fully empty my
bladder or having to re urinate
frequently or even getting like blood in
my urine and none of this was listed on
my consent forms I didn't even know that
it was a problem
that arose from taking testosterone
until after I stopped taking it and it
got worse
[Music]
all right so now while all this is
happening you're also marching down the
transition pathway right so you went
from blockers to testosterone and then
what
this is what you're about 14 now we're
about where you're 14. yeah Jesus that's
awful yeah at the at the end of fifth
grade at the end of eighth grade
um
the bully that I mentioned earlier
actually sexually assaulted me
um you know before before this point
but I was about several months on
testosterone I was very confident myself
and you know I never really cared to
like try to hide my chest or anything
because I was
maybe about like a b cup or less and I
was quite thin I would often wear
like baggy shirts and so I never really
thought it would be a problem
but
um
he had groped me in the middle of
a
classroom
um
and but before before this I actually
had a fear a very strong fear of being
sexually assaulted a lot of my my female
peers and some of the older women I knew
had been
either assaulted or raped or sexually
abused and hearing these accounts
Growing Up made me fear the same thing
eventually happened to myself and then
it did and
you know in that moment it was like
it was like glass shattering it was
it felt like I was the only person
in the room because it was as if nobody
even noticed or cared that this happened
to me
and I ended up downplaying it in in my
head it was like
well nobody noticed
and nobody nobody saw
so maybe it doesn't matter what exactly
happened what exactly happened to you if
you don't mind so that so
he walked up to you were in class yeah
no it was yeah this was this is in class
and he just walked up to me he had he
often would do things to intimidate me
and then he took a step further by
squeezing one of my breasts
uh-huh I see and you know at the time it
was just like oh it maybe it's just boys
being boys so I'll just I'll just play
it off and be a man about it and
I won't be bothered by it no there's
definitely there's definitely malevolent
intent behind that
I I knew I knew that even if it did
bother me that I wouldn't really have a
chance to speak up because if I brought
it up to the school office and they
would just leave the kid with a slap on
the wrist and he'd come back maybe like
a
maybe after like a two-day suspension
and then potentially do something worse
to me so I didn't bother right right
right right right right so that made you
feel more isolated yeah that's what you
said it made you feel right that nobody
cared yeah yeah well that's a real uh
you know a lot of people get traumatized
by malevolent say like it it's not even
exactly the physical act although it's
it's obviously also that it's the fact
that someone is doing something
literally designed to hurt you and
subjugate you and make you miserable and
so you get contact with that intent and
that's really hard on people to
encounter malevolence like that so it's
no wonder it bothered you
you know and you can think well what did
it really mean physically you know it
really didn't damage me it's like that's
not the point the point is the intent of
the person who did it and this was a
bully who was what would you say
accelerating his bullying cycle and you
know God only knows where that would
have gone because someone like that who
doesn't have enough internal constraint
there's no limit in some sense to what
they might eventually do so you had
reason to be afraid and to be you know
set back on your heels so that's really
too bad so okay so that threw you for a
loop how did that
play into your next decision
so
very soon after that was when I decided
to start binding my chest I asked my mom
to buy me a binder
buy me some binders online
um I don't know if you know what they
are but they're
they're like a compression device
covered
part of the Torso and in the in the
chest area they basically like squeeze
the breasts and make them look flatter
and you know I I wore those for about
I'd say two years before getting a
mastectomy and I got sick of it
like I would I would work out I would
swim I would walk home in super hot
weather in these things and
I just wanted to be done with it
like I I wanted to be free of wearing
this thing but at the same time I didn't
want my chest to be visible I
I was afraid of the attention that would
bring me and also like I genuinely
believed myself to be a boy I wanted to
look like a boy and be able to take my
shirt off without
without any cares and so
about halfway through my sophomore year
I told my therapist that I was seeking a
mastectomy and through a gender
specialist I was referred to a surgeon
and I had an appointment with him and
and so what did your therapist say okay
so what's happening with your therapist
during all this time I mean now so
you're uh
physiologically healthy young woman and
you've just announced that you want to
undergo a form of radical surgery that's
generally reserved for advanced stage
cancer survivors
and the upshot of that is you're hustled
off to a specialist who can facilitate
that
there's no investigation into all the
background issues that we've been
talking about instead
well it was it was just seen as it was
part of the process like there is really
no psychological evaluation yeah
um
I
yeah that's utterly appalled
you know I'm I'm so I've been
embarrassed for years to be a member of
the intellectual Academy under the
current conditions that universities uh
what would you say have have have have
put themselves into and I'm equally
embarrassed to be part of the
Therapeutic Community to hear a story
like yours it's absolutely appalling
what happened to you there's no excuse
whatsoever for it
so it's such a dereliction of
responsibility that it's almost it's
almost unimaginable
so it's really too bad that that you
weren't listened to
in a lot more detail and with a lot more
care you know because what you went
through
it's not that abnormal you know
everything you told me about your
unhappiness as a teenager the fact that
you were isolated in Middle School the
fact that you had some doubts about your
developing identity it's like yeah
that's pretty much par for the course
for adolescence some kids get through it
with a little less scarring than others
but most adolescents have a pretty damn
miserable time for about three years and
so
the fact that that led you down a path
to hormonal transformation and then
surgery and that adults aided and
embedded this you know I I have some
sympathy for your parents because when
parents are told you better support your
child or it'll be suicide it's like well
that backs them into a corner but the
medical professionals and the counselors
who dealt with you
that their their negligence borders
their negligence it doesn't just border
on the criminal it it crosses the
boundary as far as I'm concerned
okay so now you're set you go off to see
a specialist who's the specialist and
how do they treat um
it's important to note that I mean it
absolutely was negligence because not
only was I given surgery for a problem
that was psychological in nature
um and the months before that
I that was when I had been diagnosed
with depression and Social Anxiety and
when my mastercardial radiation started
started happening
I would you know I
at the beginning they told my parents
like your child will be at risk of
suicide if you don't affirm her identity
but it wasn't until after I started the
treatments
that I started
filling like feeling like committing
suicide
yeah
did you have a plan
no I never really had a plan but it was
the feeling was prevalent enough to that
it affected my day-to-day life
right right so when you assess people
for suicidality
essentially what you do is you you
investigate the structures of their
fantasies and their wishes and the more
develop the plan they have the higher
the probability is that they'll actually
commit suicide right so if it's a fully
developed plan
Place location Implement all of that
then the person's really at risk
otherwise and it sounds like this was
the case in your case it's more a marker
of generalized depression and anxiety
because that will often spin off you
know quasi-suicidal thoughts like well
maybe it would be better for everyone
else if I wasn't here or life is too
difficult and so you know it would be
simpler All Things Considered just to
bring it to an end you know that's bad
and it's often it's also associated with
a fair bit of suffering but
those thoughts in and of themselves are
not associated with a spectacular a high
risk of you know imminent suicide so
okay but in any case you were miserable
enough at this point well obviously then
you'd be looking for
what further alleviation of your of your
psychological symptoms and you said The
Binding was very uncomfortable and and
Troublesome and so for some so that also
LED you to conclude that it just might
be simpler All Things Considered since
you were already on the pathway to being
a boy just to go down the surgical route
yeah um so you were 14 when that
happened I was I was 15 at this time I
was in my my sophomore year of high
school they also started on
can treat my depression they put me they
decided to medicate me for it and
you know I from what little
from what little I knew about
about medicating depression I often
heard that ssris have all these terrible
side effects so I asked that they put me
on something with with as few side
effects as possible and they decided to
put me on Wellbutrin which I didn't know
until after I stopped doing it but it
actually has like a huge black box label
warning on it for use in children
adolescence and it actually made me feel
more suicidal
over time okay okay all right so all
right so now you're you're 15 and and
you you go see a specialist in
relationship to surgery how were you
evaluated at that point
um when you actually moved forward for
the surgery
I don't remember much of it but it was
I mean obviously they didn't really do
an evaluation of my mental health it was
just like oh so you're you're Transit
you've
you're transitioning you're you identify
as a boy and you've been on hormones for
such and such amount of time so
that was I was eligible and after my
first appointment I was I was
the the surgeon told me about a Top
surgery classroom that was taking place
in the hospital building and encouraged
me and my parents to attend it and I
went and it was I we I learned basically
the same things that I learned
um
in the surgeon's office
um you know about like the different
types of incisions and how it benefits
gender dysphoria basically just
propaganda
um there are maybe about like 15 12 to
15 or so other families in there
um I I noticed right away that
all the other kids in there
looked to be either younger than me or
like they hadn't even started on
hormones yet and I was shocked that
they were already
seeking
surgery
but it kind of I didn't really question
it much of the time it was just like oh
um
I guess
this is just normal and I've I'm not the
only one going through this
right right well and you were already a
long way down the road and so I guess
you checked off the boxes as far as the
medical practitioners were concerned but
at that point it's also for you it's
going to be increasingly difficult to
you know to reverse your decision you're
already in a couple of years
you know and that's a long time when
you're only 14 and so
so it was on to the next step so that
happened when you were 15 and so what
was the consequence of the double
mastectomy for you what's been the
consequence
um
by by this point in time
you know I was two years two or three
years on testosterone and I've been
binding for roughly the same amount of
time and my breasts had lost their shape
they didn't look like they used to
before they didn't really have
you know they didn't they didn't
to me they it just looked strange and
I actually just started developing more
more insecurities with my body
as as I went through my transition you
know like I had like these masculine
features pop up but it was all still on
a female body and there is like an
incongruence between different features
on my body and especially my breasts
like it was this masculine looking body
with quite a bit of muscle
and yet these these things were there
and they weren't really in the best
shape and
it became a source of insecurity for me
and you know I thought that even if I
wanted to I would they would my chest
would never be the same again and so
there was not really any point in in
keeping it and before I went under this
before I went over the knife they did
tell me that I was going to lose my
ability to breastfeed but it was like
I'm gonna be a man and men don't do that
I think I also I also wasn't really
thinking about being a parent at all
because
I was I was a kid
actually this was this is kind of
reminiscent of the uh
of one of the appointments for for
getting the testosterone um my
endocrinologist
asked me some questions that were
very adult in nature I was basically
being sexualized by my doctors
um they it was like are you are you
aware that
you may experience
vaginal atrophy or are you aware that
this may affect your ability to have
children as an adult and I just went
along with it was like oh yeah I know
that I don't I don't plan on having kids
and I also
hadn't had I
I never had sex by that point so I
didn't know just what what effect I knew
that would have on my body
but I was being treated as if I were
an adult with the mental factories to be
able to consent to all this and
understand what I was consenting to
but I wasn't
I was just a kid
so what happened in the aftermath of the
surgery
what was that like for you you know when
I when I woke up and I was fully
conscious all the meds had worn off and
I realized what just happened but I was
actually quite happy
you know I was like wow I just
this is a huge accomplishment this is a
huge step and
you know I can finally be myself and I
was looking forward to being healed and
eventually being able to
go out um
since swim and work out and just hang
out without a shirt and look like all
the other boys and not have to worry
about wearing this uncomfortable
restrictive thing
and
you know I'm I got it was an outpatient
surgery
um
got sent home pretty soon after that and
I had a
comfy I guess you'd say a few weeks
after that because my mom had to take
some time off work to just help me run
the house it was a major surgery in my
upper body and I lost a considerable
amount of my range of motion I couldn't
even lift up my arms over my head
and so maybe about like three or four
months afterward so I wasn't really in a
state to be going out all my own
um
but after
about a week or so was when reality
started to hit
um
I had to get my stitches taken out a few
days afterward
and The Sensation
was
just
insane like
they had to cut and rearrange some newer
vendings so it was like
it was none
but I could also feel everything that
they're doing when they're taking out
the stitches
ends
I was
it felt so disgusting and once I went
home and I was able to
finally bathe again
that was when
I started having to that's that's when I
had to take off the
surgical binder and the dressings and
looked down
that
what was left in my chest you know I had
these big scars and all these markings
from
from a surgical marker and on top of
that
um I I I will just a warning I will get
into graphic detail here but
the type of uh
incision that I got was called a
was called double incision with nipple
grafts meaning that they would
not only take out the breast tissue and
Contour the chests to look more
masculine they would also
um
remove like the
the way it was explained to me I guess
because I was young and they were trying
to make it more digestible to a 15 year
old
was that they would
they would um
leave like a deep deep scrapes on both
sides of my chest kind of like a deep
knee scrape but more more controlled
and they would
they would remove my nipples and then
place them in that area of scraped skin
and they called a more masculine
positioning and shape
it's Barbarian to say the least and
when I took the dressings off
when I looked down
they were the graphs they were they were
black because
you know they during the
during the surgery during the operation
the blood supply was cut off and so the
outer layer of skin had died
and they said that that was how it was
supposed to be and that was just part of
the process but I couldn't bear to see
that part of my body and I had to see
that every night I had to I had to
change my
I had to that was what I had to look at
every single night after every bath
after every shower
what what happened to you
um if in in relationship to sensation
like
what because that's a long-term you know
physiological and sexual consequence and
so you lose the ability to breastfeed
obviously and there's a profound
physiological alteration in your
appearance but what happens to you on
the sensation side what has happened
um it's certainly not the same it's
gotten a lot better over the years I
mean
initially I would get like a lot of
it felt like
Sparks electricity as like my the nerve
endings were vac but
it's
it's it's it's strange like I can
move like a hand over
a certain area of my chest and it'll
feel like it's in my arm or something
and I have basically basically no
erogenous sensation in the graphs
yeah okay okay
so it wasn't long after this
that you started to have doubts about
what you were doing now you told me
earlier in this in this discussion that
at some point you started thinking about
having children and so but then also
that you decided to stop your transition
when you were 16. so
how did that lay itself out after you
had the surgery and how did you come to
the decision that the decision you had
made was not a good one
um
not long after
um I'd say maybe about a month or two
I started realizing that
you know I miss looking pretty and
having softer features in a more
feminine form
um but this was something that I kind of
repressed for a while it was
I mean I was about three years on
testosterone by this point and I didn't
even look like a woman anymore I thought
there was no going back and there would
be no point
but
at the same time I would also buy makeup
and skirts and dresses and just wear it
in the comfort of my room or when nobody
was home to see it
and this caused a great deal of distress
for me and
after the surgery I just kept getting
worse I just kept justifying in my head
as
it being part of the post-op process but
I never really got any better and it
wasn't until
maybe about 11 months after the surgery
that
I realized
what the problem was and
you know I I had to I was taking a
psychology class at this point I had a
adolescent
I had a chapter on
on Child Development and parenting and
one of the
one of the lessons was about the Harlow
experiments with the rhesus monkeys the
ones
exploring like the relationship between
mother and her child how things like uh
physical affection and breastfeeding
affect that and I realized that
my breasts were so much more than just
sexual organs I mean there were a means
of not only feeding my kid
but also
I lost so much more than that of
providing them with love and attention
yeah well look you know there's a woman
named Tiffany Fields she she studied
under she studied the work of a man
named ryak Banks up and panks up showed
that in order for rat pups to develop
properly they had to be physically
stimulated touch licked loved the uh
experimenters can duplicate that by
massaging them with the end of a pencil
eraser anyways Tiffany Fields showed
that if you took premature kids that
were in an incubator and you massage
them three times a day for 10 minutes
that they developed as fast physically
as children in utero there's a huge body
of research showing that that skin to
skin contact
is crucial that's physical love that's
skin to skin contact is a crucial part
of establishing the what would you call
it the domain of love that's necessary
for children to flourish food shelter
you know the provision of adequate water
etc those Basics are necessary but that
physical contact and love is equally
necessary and so it's definitely the
case that well breastfed children tend
to thrive more more thoroughly right and
that's partly a nutritional issue but
it's also partly an issue of well of the
fact that a lot of the love that's
maternal love that entices children into
life is a consequence of physical
contact
so yeah well that's a hell of a
realization so that started to Dawn on
you in high school after you had the
surgery I felt like a monster
and you were starting to think about
having kids at that point and and so so
why what do you think that was triggered
by the surgery um
like what switched you I think
it was most of that class
I mean I was I was learning a lot about
myself and also
about the
about parenting and about children
and that was that was when I realized
like
I think I would have kids someday
and you know I started really thinking
about it like not only
not only about how it relates to having
lost my breasts but also
you know my fertility might be affected
by having to start a testosterone so
young
and do you know do you know whether that
is the case now has have you been tested
in any manner that indicates whether the
blockers and the testosterone have
interfered with your fertility I don't
know
um
I mean by the time that I started I was
I did start having periods but they were
I was so young by that but at that point
I they weren't they weren't regular I
was only having about three to four per
year that was also another source of
stress for me about being a woman
um I felt yeah right it was it was scary
like all the other girls my age would
talk about like how you know they had
they got theirs every month or every two
months and
you know I learned some myth now but
they would talk about how like their
Cycles would supposedly sync with like
family members or friends and I was like
that why isn't that happening to me
and so I it was just it was just
a thing another thing the pile that made
me feel like I was broken
um luckily after stopping right right
right luckily after stopping about two
months later I got my period back and
it's been
surprisingly quite regular since I don't
know if I went through some development
well that's a that's a good song that's
a good sign right well that's a good
sign that must be a relief
so to speak
but I mean there's so many other factors
that play into that I just it's I
haven't
been able to get tested and I'm
I'm just not really sure of what's to
come but yeah I'm hopeful
right right right right right right
okay so when did you when did you stop
taking the testosterone and when did you
announce this to your parents well when
did you announce this to yourself and
then to your parents and and all the
other people around you who knew
um
I think after my junior year wrapped up
one night I just kind of broke down
crying and I realized that I regretted
my transition and I called a friend and
I texted my mom I couldn't call her or
talk to her about in person because
you know I I had a lot of guilt I had a
lot of Shame and I didn't want to
I didn't want to let her and Dad and the
rest of the family down after so many
years of doing this
and they they invested they invested
their time and their money into doing
this since it was
pretty much for nothing and I hated that
it was also just shameful to admit that
was wrong after so much time especially
since
I didn't even look like a girl anymore
by that point
right
yeah well it's quite it's quite
remarkable in some sense that you did
reverse your decision and do you you
seem to be indicating to me that it was
the realization that you wanted to have
children that was the was that the real
that was the real telling
moment of transformation was it
it was definitely one of the biggest
catalysts
and how do you think you figured that
out because that you know it's actually
pretty young to figure that out I mean
I've seen I've met many women now who
you know there's lots of women your age
who are absolutely hell-bent and
convinced that they're never going to
have kids that the only pathway forward
to them that's valid is the career
pathway but I'll tell you that you know
I'm 60 years old now and I've worked
with women in female dominated
businesses my whole life because I'm in
the psychological profession and so
that's female dominated and uh
virtually every woman I've ever met with
with almost no exceptions and this
includes extremely high achieving women
on the career front
pretty much by the time they're in their
late 20s the their primary
goal is to have a child
and that's even the case now sometimes
that kicks in for women later than that
I've seen that as well but it's an
extremely rare woman who
goes through her entire young life
without being seized by the desire to
have a child and so but it's early in
your case so and it's strange right in
some ways because you'd fought against
this so hard why the hell do you think
it made itself manifest as a desire
when you were 16 like did you think you
knew that you were really like on The
Cutting Edge in some sense you know that
if you kept pushing this you were really
going to sacrifice your ability to have
kids or what do you think produce the
realization I think you know I already
had my guard down by that point
um because
this was around when uh
when covet hit and all there were all
the restrictions from the place and I
was
um
basically doing online school only and I
had a lot of isolation from the outside
world and this this caused me
a significant amount of stress but it
also
allowed for a lot more time to be alone
and reflect and so it opened up my mind
a little bit and
so so so what were you fantasizing about
on the family front when
you were looking forward into the future
you were thinking about having did you
did you have some idea of how many kids
you wanted to have did you have some
idea about the like the marriage or the
family structure what what was making
itself manifest in your fantasy um I
mean when I started I was so young that
I wasn't even thinking about all that
yet
um but as the years passed and
I started to think about like my
adulthood what I wanted to do as an
adult
um
that stopped my that thought started to
pop into my head a little bit more
um I never really thought about it
very much and so
I learned about about
child psychology and
just being a parent I think I would have
naturally had that
um that realization
if
I guess if I knew more about about
parenting and and yeah and family hey do
you do you know when you were a kid when
you were a kid do you know if you played
with dolls yeah I did
you did okay so that was there do you
can you remember whether or not you
enjoyed that I know that's a long time
yeah I did and were they baby dolls or
were they Barbies and brats
okay so they were teenage dolls did you
have any baby dolls um
not that I can remember
okay okay see that's an end that's
interesting you know even among
chimpanzees if you allow chimpanzee
juveniles free toy choice the males will
pick trucks and wield things and gadgets
and the females will pick dolls and the
female chimps will carry the dolls
around teddy bears and so forth for for
months and develop a very deep
attachment to them and you know one of
the things it's really necessary for
young girls and perhaps for young boys
but certainly for young girls to play
with baby dolls it's really necessary
because that's all part of that
practicing that that that deep female
role and you know without that
well you don't have a chance that's how
kids think okay they think by playing
and if they don't have a chance to play
that out then well they don't they don't
explore that and so it didn't even make
it manifest in your own life until you
were like 16 and had gone through all
this bloody misery
all right so when did you start thinking
about taking legal action and and why do
you think that's justifiable that was
quite a bit further down the line um
I should probably go into first about
the detransition process for me and what
led up to
me eventually starting to speak out and
just doing that yeah
um
when I had this realization
I mean that that night when when I broke
down and I talked to my friend and my
mom and my dad about it
um but that was the night that I stopped
taking testosterone and I decided that I
would just
grow my hair out and buy new clothes and
just figure things out from there
um
I went for about
a week just not really doing anything I
was just kind of at Rock Bottom at that
point and
I didn't always see a reason to do
anything anymore I just really I just
stayed in my bed or in my bedroom all
day didn't really go out except to use
the restroom or get some food but Mom
and Dad would come and check in on me
and
it was it was comforting and that that
kept me going
um
and then I had to figure out all the
figure out everything from there pretty
much on my own
um
I
I told my endocrinologist I told my
therapist my endocrinologist and my
gender Specialists that I
regretted my transition very deeply that
I was going to stop
and I didn't really get a whole lot of
guidance on it I guess they really
couldn't because it would be against the
law to
um
suggest anything other than well that's
a tricky one right because well
hypothetically once you announce that
they're also legally bound to go along
with that
right so so they could have they could
have agreed with you I mean look I have
a certain amount of sympathy for
counselors and medical practitioners
because they're facing Supreme hell on
the on the on their regulatory College
front but but having said that I would
also say that their fundamental duty of
care is to the individual and not to the
bloody regulating colleges and so but
they could have they could have taken
your
regret seriously you said that did you
face opposition or was it just or was it
just a matter of lack of guidance it was
mostly lack of guidance nobody really
opposed it but you know I started
requesting
blood tests from my endocrinologist and
uh when I got the I specifically I
specifically told her that I no longer
identify as male and I want the
guidelines for a female my age and when
I got the results back they were sent
with the guidelines for the average sex
hormone levels for a teenage boy
so that was kind of the first
that was one of the first moments that
really woke me up to
the fact that these people
weren't going to help me
well you know it's weird eh because if
your medical people were so convinced
that you were a hundred percent right
when you decided to transition to begin
with and they were you were right enough
to take the hormones and have the
surgery you'd think that there'd be some
resistance to your sudden change of
heart but it sounds like you you
basically encountered the same
lackadaisical response to the second
decision that you did to the first
decision
so which it's not surprising although
it's horrible yeah I was basically
entirely patient-led
right right okay so all right so you
decided to take legal action and and so
walk us through that
yeah
um
earlier this year I started to
to start speaking out publicly about my
experience with transitioning and then
stopping transition
before that
um I actually had lost a lot of friends
both from school and online over it
um
over the course of my D transition
because
um
a lot of them I I had a pretty strong
change in a lot of My Views and a lot of
them disagreed with me heavily and they
they were very upset with me
um
there was one person who kept harassing
me just because I regretted it and said
that I deserve to feel that way that I
didn't deserve to have parents who loved
me enough to let me go through this and
there are a lot of others who said that
I was just making them uncomfortable and
that I shouldn't be I shouldn't be
voicing any of this because it would be
harming other real transgender people
who needed this treatment
and I I did yeah the real ones I see I
see I gave into this pressure and I did
stop talking about it for a while but I
also was
I also got involved in communities
online of people who regretted their
Transitions and I realized that
that wasn't the case at all and
that
I just couldn't shut up because this is
something that's happening more often
than even I thought
was was happening I didn't even know
that each transition was a thing until
after until it happened to me
and you know I I knew that
there's got to be so many other people
in the situation especially kids
who are being pressured by their their
friends
to stay silent about their pain
and somebody
it's not necessarily that I want to
speak out about it but I feel I feel
called to
and so I started this year and what do
you think what what do you think is the
core of your claim that you fell pray to
say medical and counseling malpractice
what do you think was done wrong with
you
um
quite a lot actually
um
the most immediate thing I can think of
would be the fact that the consent forms
didn't weren't they weren't really
comprehensive they were very vague they
didn't list a
didn't list um
didn't have nearly enough information on
them and
I was also just
too young to really fathom what any of
this meant and they
you know you can make the argument that
my parents well you know consent consent
has to be well consent has to be
documented but it also has to be
informed and informed means you have to
understand what you're consenting to and
so from my perspective like especially
when you were really young say around 12
and you first went into therapy there
should have been a very deep
investigation into your background and
then a laying out of a whole
comprehensive range of options and a
lengthy discussion of the consequence of
all of those options and your parents
after the discussion had taken place
with you your parents should have been
brought into that and they should have
been walked through the same range of
options and then you all should have
been offered
you what what I would say the
opportunity or the necessity to take a
fair amount of time to really think it
through you know on the fundamental
basis that well we won't do anything
precipitous until it's necessary right
and that that hearkens back to the idea
that if you leave most kids with gender
dysphoria B you know most of them
identify as homosexual as I said
eventually but most of them the vast
majority of them accept their biological
status and so
so the consent issue it isn't only that
the forms were vague and didn't detail
out the you know the full range of
consequences it's that you needed to be
walked through in great detail
all of the issues that were relevant to
you on the psychological and medical
front all the options that were
available to you and the pros and cons
of all those options and that should
have been something that took I would
think that I can't see in any possible
way that that could have been done with
any degree of thoroughness in something
under six months of weekly therapy and I
would say that's an absolute minimum to
walk anyone through something as
complicated as what you laid out
so that's on the informed yeah right
yeah they really presented this as as
basically the only option so both me and
my parents
um
and I also
the problem with me starting at so young
was not only that I couldn't consent I
couldn't really fathom
the full just the full picture of things
um
I've also experienced I'm still
experiencing
a wide range of complications to this
day
um
you know from the
the surgery
you know I'll never be able to
breastfeed
um I'll never have that erogenous
sensation in my chest back
um
I I'll never have my breasts back
a reconstruction will do nothing for me
and it might make things worse actually
because I'm
I've had some complications pop up this
year with the graphs they I have to
cover them up with bandages or I'll say
they'll
I don't know what's going on with them I
tried to consult my surgeon about it and
she
didn't really didn't really
didn't really investigate he gave me
advice that made my the complications
worse even and actually temporarily gave
me an affection but I have to wear I
have to bandage up every day so that it
doesn't like leak all over my clothing
or bedding
and Jesus from the from the
the hormones and blockers um
I've been experiencing some joint pains
mainly in my my arms my legs and my back
and uh yeah
I
I still have issues with my my urinary
tract I have to use the restroom pretty
frequently and
I didn't even know that this was
possible this is like a pretty huge
quality of life issue that I'm
experiencing and I'm just
I'm just not really getting any help for
it and on top of that
I'm
I do I do hate to speak about it but
I'm experiencing
sexual dysfunction at the age of 18
that's something that women usually go
through
when
when they're in their 40s to 50s
right right
how is this supposed to know
so so let's talk for a moment about how
you got your lawyers and where you are
on the legal Battlefront
so
not only is
what's happened to me completely
unethical completely wrong it's caused
me a lot of physical damage and
emotional damage as well I'm still
picking up the pieces of my life to this
day and
I often find myself feeling like a
broken woman all because of a choice
that I made
that I was allowed to make as a kid
and
I think it's very clear just how wrong
all this is none of this should have
been allowed to happen
what has happened legally have you have
you served a set of people with notice
that you're taking legal proceedings and
or are you still in the in the planning
stages of that
um
so we've filed a letter of intent to sue
against Kaiser my healthcare provider as
well as the the hospital that I
underwent the surgery at and the surgeon
who did it the gender specialist who
referred me to that surgeon and the
endocrinologist who had put me on
hormones
um we're still we're still in the 90-day
period
right so this is all just this is all
just unfolding now so you're going to
end up with a pretty damn thorough
medical and legal education by the time
you're done all of this and uh media
education as well
that's for sure
so look we should wrap this part up um
for everyone who's watching and
listening I'm going to talk to Chloe for
another half an hour on the daily wire
plus platform I think what I'm going to
do I often walk people through the
development of their career but that's
not relevant in her situation what I'm
going to do instead is talk to Chloe
about She was recently at an event with
Matt Walsh and I want to talk to her
about that and I want to talk to her
about the response she's got from the
gender uh let's say uh ideologues and
activists in relationship to
going public with her decision to
detransition so we're going to delve
into that for about half an hour and so
if those of you who are watching and
listening found this interesting and
you're inclined switch over to the Daily
wire plus platform and we'll fill in the
political end of this at least to some
degree and Chloe thank you very much for
talking to me today and I'm really
it's really uh what happened to you is
really unforgivable in my estimation
you know it's you were very badly
mishandled by the people who should have
been taking care of you on the
professional front
and you were you were
you know offered a pathway forward that
I can see to be highly tempting for
someone in your situation
but there were many many many many other
options available to you on the
therapeutic front that would have
resolved the problems that you've had to
the degree that human problems can ever
be resolved without having to wander
through this bloody catastrophic
Labyrinth of pain and suffering and
confusion that you've been subject to
for the last five years and so I hope
that
you can get yourself back on proper
footing and move forward and and I wish
you all the luck there is on the legal
front I hope your damn legal system in
the United States Isn't So corrupted
already by all this woke nonsense so
that it'll be impossible for you to
proceed but I suspect that the medical
community who's being complicit in this
kind of Butchery has an awful shock
waiting for them on the legal front that
certainly started to manifest itself in
the UK with the closing of the Tavistock
clinic and I think there's a thousand
lawsuits right now pending in
relationship to the Tavistock clinic so
the tide is beginning to turn and when
it turns there's going to be an awful
lot of uh reparations made on the part
of of culpable medical professionals and
their counseling acolytes so good luck
with that eh and keep your head up and
we'll flip over to the Daily wire plus
platform for all those you watching and
listening thank you very much for your
time and attention and thanks again
Chloe for uh being willing to wander
through this you know
relatively painful personal territory
thank you so much
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com